[Raegan] Hi.
Oh, Raegan, you look so beautiful.
Thank you, so do you, I'm so happy to be back.
Oh my God. I'm so happy to be back with you.
And I feel like we both got sort of,
like, a falling collar memo and the fact
that reading is your passion and the way that you read
so voraciously, and you know, it just really inspired us.
And so we want to bring in our correspondent
and resident book reviewer, someone I started
this journey with. My partner in crime,
Jonah Larson!
(audience applause)
[Jonah] Hey, Drew!
Hi, Jonah, how are you?
I'm doing so good.
I haven't seen you for a long time
and I'm so glad to be back on the show,
talking about a book.
Raegan, you have a book club and Jonah is just one
of my favorite readers, which is why we wanted to
do a whole Reviewed by Jonah series.
And we thought Raegan, Jonah, Jonah, Raegan.
And we hooked you guys up
with some young viewers to discuss your latest pick.
So tell everybody what the book is.
It's called It Came From This Guy
by Chelsea Sedoti and it's such a good book.
Well, Jonah, how did it go?
When you talked to other young ladies and gentlemen.
It was really enjoyable because this book has so
many different elements and different layers of it.
And there's so many different perspectives you
can take based on one story
that you really have to read the book
to be able to understand what I'm talking about.
Well, let's see how the book club went.
Let's roll some clips.
(upbeat music)
So basically It Came From The Sky is about
two brothers who were doing a science experiment
and it went totally wrong.
And they blamed it on an alien invasion.
My favorite part of the book was the ending
where Jake Lindsey Oswald was exposed as a fraud
and the town's sixty-three foot tall lava lamp exploded.
Steven, what was your favorite part of the book?
My favorite part was when the two brothers were exposed
and had to tell the police officer
and the agent about the hoax.
Oh, well, my part of the story was the same as yours.
It actually was when the lava lamp exploded.
That one was like, Oh my God, what's going to happen next?
You know?
And that one just was like a page turner.
Gideon's dream job is to become an engineer for NASA.
Raegan, what's your dream job?
Well, I'm actually kind of doing it right now with acting
but I'd also love to add a few more things.
I'm obsessed with horses.
So I would love to be a horse trainer.
I would love to be a Marine biologist or a vet.
Oh, wow, I love animals too.
So those folks made some great options.
Now as surprise for you guys,
We've invited the author
of It Came From The Sky, Chelsea Sedoti.
[Steven] Hi.
[Chelsea] Hi guys. How's it going?
[Raegan] Hi! Good, it's so amazing to meet you.
It's awesome to meet all of you.
And I'm so honored that you're talking
about It Came From The Sky today.
We have some questions for you.
Where did you get your inspiration to write
It Came From The Sky.
Have you, by any chance have had any
extra-terrestrial activity in your life?
So I've been afraid of the aliens
since I was a little kid.
I'm not sure why, but I think I might have walked
in on an episode of Unsolved Mysteries
when I was like six.
I was wondering, are your characters based
on real people or did you
just come up with them on the spot?
I don't like to make my characters too much
like real people, because I feel
like when I've tried to do that,
I go back and reread the pages and it's just not working.
What advice would you give someone who wants to
write a book?
Most of all, just write, but it's just one of
those things where the only way to get better is to practice
and practice and practice.
Woo, thank you Chelsea very much for stopping by
and answering our questions about It Came From The Sky,
and make sure to get your hands on a copy.
We Came From The Sky by Chelsea Sedoti
because it's available everywhere
books are sold and back that you, Drew.
Thank you, Jonah.
Raegan, what was your biggest takeaway from the book?
I think my biggest takeaway was probably
to always tell the truth.
This book centers around, as you may know, like a hoax
that these two brothers just created literally overnight.
And as the boys just continue on with this lie
it's like becomes like its own.
It has a life of the town.
And as the hoax like gets out
of their control, more and more people
keep getting roped in.
And I would, what I feel like as just always tell the truth.
Everything you just said is so true.
So astute. Jonah, what about you?
What was your biggest takeaway from the book?
Well, with the book like this
you have to have a couple of main takeaways.
One of them is don't keep others arm's lengths away.
Open up to them and be more open and like,
sometimes you just have to be vulnerable.
And that really helps with your relationships, but also,
of course be honest, and they have much bigger consequences
than if you just accept the consequence right
at the start and just admit to starting the hoax.
You're absolutely right.
You guys, it has a snowball effect, and what starts
out this big can become so massive and lies, grow
and everything you said is just so true,
that it's better to just deal with it
in the moment. We have to be kind of strong, brave
and responsible, and it's just a wonderful quality.
And I think you guys both really took it
out of this book and you're using it
as a shining example of what you can learn
from such a wonderful, entertaining story.
I'm really moved by both of your reviews.
Thank you.
Raegan, thank you so much
for bringing your book club to the show.
We're huge admirers of it here and Jonah, always,
thank you.
Let's do this again as soon as possible.
We'll pick another book and do this again.
Yes.
Thank you so much.
[Jonah] Thank you.
Thank you. Jonah, we'll see you very soon.
And young Sheldon airs every Thursday at 8:30,
7:30 central on CBS.
(upbeat music)